مرحبا احداث كثيره طلعت على حياه الفنانه
شيرين عبد الوهاب مؤخرا تغير فيها تماما
عن الصوره الموسيقي طارق مذكور والكاتب
ايمن بهجت قمر رقم تكرار اسمي هيما من
قبلها كثيرا في فتره ما قبل دخولها الى
المستشفى مصادر كواليس اكدت انه لا خلاف
معهما الا ان ايضا لا تواصل حيث كانت هناك
مشاريع فنيه على الصعيد التمثيل والغناء
بينها وبينها ولكنها حاليا عالقه بينما
يشغل ايضا قمر بنجاح في المتحده للسلاح في
حين ينشغل طارق مذكور جديد ومع عدد من
النجوم ابرزهم نانسي عجرم
في اول بطوله لها تطل الفنانه ريم الحبيب
قريبه من مسلسل على الهوى يشاركها البطوله
النجمين علي السبع و عبد العزيز الكريم
المسلسل الدرامي اجتماعيه يتحدث عن وزير
يقرر الاستقاله فجاه فيدخل في صراع كبير
بسبب نيه الكشف عن قضايا فساد كبيره ومن
المفترض ان يبدا العمل اللي كتبوا نديم
النجم واخرجوا عبد الاله هزازي في شهر
ديسمبر القادم على شاهد ويتكون من ثماني
الحلقه
الاولى
وهو ملف الفساد علما باننا لا بان احداث
العمل لا تموت للواقع باي سنه
لان حرسنا ان يكون التصوير بشكل كامل في
محافظه الاحساء في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
الحين انال او ينال العمل جانبه من الواقع
[موسيقى]
اعلى مهرجان البحر الاحمر السينمائي
الدولي عن اطلاق برنامج ايام المواهب حيث
سيكون من السابع وحتى الثامن من ديسمبر
القادم البرنامج عباره عن مجموعه من
الاجتماع
الافلام
فرديه تساعدهم على السيد افكارهم الى
مشاريع ملموسه حيث ستتم دعوه مجموعه من
المواهب الدوليه والسعوديه بالاضافه
المخرجين ومنتجين لحضور مجموعه من
المحاضرات التحفيزيه وليس العمل المنسقه
خصوص لهم جنبا الى برنامج ارشادي خاص يعمل
على تاهيلهم يتصور المشروعهم القادم على
افضل وقت
سخريه كبيره طالعه الفنان كريم فهمي بعد
اعلان اقتباس مخرج الفرنسي لفكره في امه
هاتوا لي راجل اللي صدر عام او 2013 في
الفيلم انا لست رجل سهلا فرنسي واللي انتج
عام خان او و18 وايضا اقتباس مخرج هندي
اخر الفيلم علي بابا اللي انطلق عرض عام
2018 مثيل من دقيقه اخر انتج عام 2020
واوضح كريم فهمي انه لا يقصد التباهي بمجد
الشخصي كمؤلف وانما فقط يطالب الجمهور
ببعض التقدير وادراك ان الغرب يقتبس من
العرب كثيرا الا ان ما قالوا لم يجد
تفاعلا جدي من الجمعه
لنفس المخرجه
الفيلم ده اتعرض في مهرجان كيف سنه 2010
وبعد كده نزلته على اليوتيوب 2014 في
الوقت اللي انت فيه موجه جديده من الفيلم
اتواصل مع المخرجه عشان اشوف رايات كان
سعر التواصل معها وردت ببساطه قالت لي همم
احمد انا ما كنتش اعرف الفيلم المصري ده
همم وانا كنت عامله فيلم قصير 2010 نزلته
على اليوتيوب 2014
شركه ناس شافته واعجبها متوسط معايا وطلبت
مني ان انا اعمل نسخه طويله منه اا فيلم
قصير كان هو مصدر الهامي الوحيد ويمكن
يكون كريم فهمي يتفرج عليه ويستحمل منه
حتى ان الفيلم هندي ماخوذ عن فيلم كوري
سنه 2008 اسمه اسكندر ميكرز
المقدماتهم
وقال ان العمل معها كل مره يخرج احساس
مختلف حيث يؤكد انه هناك تعاولات كبيره
وقريبه بينهما يتوقع ان تكون اكثر نجاحا
من تعاوناتهم الفنيه السابقه
[موسيقى]
همم
لذلك من من يقدم
صدق
واحساس وموهبه
في جمهور راح يتخبروني اقول انا مع
احترامي للعراق ولكن اختلف معك
لانه صوتها
نادر يعني على سبيل المثال شيرين عبد
الوهاب يمكن الحضور في فنانين حضور حضوركم
اقوى من صوتها يعني صوتهم همم
اقوى من صوتها ولكن تملك احساس يمكن ما
يملكونه اغلب الوطن العربي كذلك نفس
المعادله اصيل
عندي احساس
يمكن صعب انه يتكرر